well for one thing i can do a zoom call
um i'm just kidding but um i think that
you know how i develop as a leader i'm
it's you know it's going to evolve my
mother was you know a wonderful gracious
so is my dad
you know maybe i'll be a little more
hands-on you know maybe i'll be a little
bit more
um
involved with some of the younger staff
and
you know i'd like to learn way more
about our analytics team for instance um
i know they're excellent but you know i
kind of want to get briefed on what they
do so i mean i think there'll be things
that i may dive into a little more
deeply than my
mother or my father would have um
but you know and we'll see how the how
the leadership develops from there
[Music]
that's the voice of sheila ford hamp the
new principal owner of the detroit lions
daughter of martha firestone ford and
the late william clay ford when mr ford
passed in 2014 martha firestone ford
took over as the principal owner and now
she hands the baton to her daughter
sheila fordham there was a long period
of time where people assumed bill ford
jr would take over the franchise there
was something that happened amid the
many years of dysfunction
that the lions have experienced really
five or six decades when you look at the
full scope of of the futility it's been
dysfunctional and now sheila fordham
chris has a chance to be the one to turn
around a team that has been
never to a super bowl not to a
a playoff victory since 1991 so that
there's a there's a low bar in relation
to what she's inheriting we'll see how
high she can move the bar up
yeah i mean we'll see you're right i
mean it's a franchise that's you know
not been consistent that that's the to
be nice about it well they have been
consistent no they have big ones because
they've been
bad right
yes they have i know uh and you know i
think maybe this new ownership maybe
maybe sheila has the the right approach
maybe that's what they need in detroit a
little bit maybe there is a a need for a
little bit more of a hands-on approach
and things like that to be involved with
ownership maybe that can help change
around the organization you know i am a
believer in bob quinn and matt patricia
i think they can change things around i
think we've seen the culture change
there already uh but yeah
as we know i mean this is not one of the
prime organizations in football and uh
we'll see sheila hampton good luck to
her with with all of this
there's a sweet spot there
being present and involved right and
around and having that accountability
and that that message that ownership
cares but stopping short of meddling
stopping don't go overboarding right the
people who you've hired to run the
football operation there's a sweet spot
and we'll see if she can land in it
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports